We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me as an
author and associate professor of
Philosophy at the College of William and
Mary.
Chris Freeman.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
All right,
man.
We're going to do philosophy for an
hour.
Are you ready?
Sounds good.
You are prepared.
I feel the jacket shirt combo.
It's very philosophy said.
Give me the rubin.
Let's talk philosophy because I think
one of the things that I try to do on
this show is I talk about philosophies
more than people ideas more than people.
And it seems to me we live in a time
where we don't do a lot of philosophy
and idea stuff.
Well,
and I guess that's maybe why,
why people are watching this.
So let's do a little philosophy one.
Oh,
one with you.
Give me just some of the basics of what
people should understand about
philosophy.
Okay.
Well,
yeah,
that's a great question.
How's that for an open ended question to
start a.
yeah,
something might take the hour,
but uh,
yeah.
So I think,
you know,
at the fundamental level,
philosophy is about challenging
assumptions.
I think one thing that makes philosophy
different from other sorts of academic
disciplines is that you can't really
take anything for granted.
So when you're,
you know,
doing philosophy,
you have to justify why killing people
is wrong,
for example,
a why feeding the hungry is good and all
of these things that we take for granted
at the level of everyday life philosophy
calls into question and I think that's
really important.
And so the kinds of philosophical
questions that I'm most interested in
are ones having to do with moral right
and wrong justice,
injustice,
the moral importance of economic
equality,
these sorts of things,
uh,
and also the,
the ethics of public policy.
So for example,
one thing that non philosophical
disciplines can do is make predictions
about what a given policy is likely to
do.
So we'll opening the borders lead to
higher unemployment,
higher gdp,
something like that.
Um,
but all things considered,
they can't really tell us what the right
thing to do is say,
okay.
Suppose it turns out that opening
borders will slightly increase domestic
unemployment,
but it also will mean that a certain
workers and the developing world will
see their incomes rise by 300 percent.
For example,
this leaves open the question,
what should we do?
Is that a trade off that we should make?
And that's really what philosophy tries
to answer is what should we do,
all things considered.
All right,
so in a little bit we're going to get to
some of your moral philosophies that you
care about,
an economic philosophies and,
and,
uh,
immigration and a bunch of other things
in just a little bit.
But first I'm curious,
what got you interested in philosophy in
the first place?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
So I think it was doing philosophy
before I realized I was doing philosophy
because arguing,
let's say good natured arguing was the
family tradition in my household.
So ever since I was a little kid,
uh,
you know,
my parents and my sister and I,
we would argue about religion and,
and these sorts of things,
right and wrong,
the economy.
And when I got a little bit older,
I started reading things in philosophy
and economics,
columns,
articles and things like that.
And I realized that there was this kind
of formal discipline called philosophy
where you could argue about right and
wrong and justice and injustice and if
you were very lucky you could get a job
doing this.
If I get paid to do this.
Not a lot of jobs of jobs.
Not paid very much either,
but it's Kinda like saying,
you know,
you can get paid to eat ice cream for a
living.
I thought okay,
that's,
that's a pretty good gig if I can get
it.
And so that was Kinda the start of the
trajectory into philosophy.
Yeah.
You know,
it's interesting because I came from a
very similar family in that regard where
we argued about everything from
economics and religion and all those
things.
And I guess perhaps if this is what led
you here,
it's Kinda what led me here as well.
But we're missing that these days.
Don't you think like that must infuriate
you as someone that cares about ideas.
When you watch the news and watch all
these people that are aren't arguing
from like a principled position or
something like philosophically thought
out position,
but just from like a party place or a
partisan place must drive you nuts.
It does.
It does because,
right?
I care about ideas.
I care fundamentally about good
arguments.
So this is something that I hope happens
to my students in my classes is they
come in with a set of preconceptions.
They have their partisan political
beliefs.
Everybody does.
I have my partisan political beliefs,
but I hope we can try as hard as we can
to just focus on the arguments,
think critically and maybe change our
minds even if it means admitting that we
were wrong or uh,
you know,
finding out that we have different
political or religious beliefs from our
friends,
we should really just follow wherever
the arguments lead us.
Do you actually like it when you find
out you were wrong on something?
Because when I've had the moments on
this show and the,
and the most famous one is when I had
larry elder in here and he just kind of
beat me senseless with facts and you
know,
and we've since become friends and he
was on just recently and I loved the guy
that it was scary in the moment,
like sitting there in the moment of
being beaten is not fun,
but afterwards when you go,
Whoa,
that's what it's about.
It's actually pretty cool.
Yes.
So I don't like,
like you said in the moment,
I don't like being threatened by it
because I got a couple of things I'm
going to expect nothing less.
Yeah.
But,
but longterm,
I think that's right.
It shows growth.
And the funny thing is that what are we
afraid of when it comes to changing our
minds and admitting when we're wrong,
what's the harm in that?
And I really,
I liked the process of arguing it's,
you know,
a form of recreation or something like a
form of exercise.
Um,
I think,
I think it was Edmund Burke who said
something like,
the person who challenged my adversary
is actually my best friend or something
like this.
So the person that is willing to argue
with you in good faith and genuinely
cares about getting at what's true
rather than what maybe confirms their
prior political beliefs,
that's,
you know,
that's the person that I want to hang
out with.
I just don't want to talk with one of my
best friends growing up.
Uh,
his name's are Greek,
so he was all into Greek philosophy and
all that and he was my intellectual
sparring
partner for them from,
from literally from 12 years old til,
well past college.
Even now.
And we ironically,
we actually agree more now than ever
before,
which is sort of weird because we both
had sort of reverse a philosophical
journeys or political journeys.
But that's actually what it's all about.
So tell me a little bit about some of
the philosophers that have affected you.
So one of my favorites is probably John
Stuart Mill.
So he was a classical liberal.
He so his,
what's known as a utilitarian,
and this is a moral theory that
essentially says the right thing to do
is the thing that has the best
consequences,
the thing that produces the most
happiness for everybody who's affected,
I find that view,
attractive and,
and moral philosophy.
But he was also,
he was a classical liberal politically,
uh,
he was a big defender of free speech
free discussion in particular.
His book on Liberty is probably the
single greatest defense of freedom of
speech.
I traveled with it,
you know,
I'm on tour right now.
I travel with it.
It's a thin book.
Everyone should have it.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
So what.
Okay.
So you mentioned classical liberalism.
Everyone knows my feelings on this.
Do you see any meaningful distinction
between classical liberalism and
libertarianism at this point?
I think that libertarianism is probably
a bit narrower than classical
liberalism,
so,
but this is a matter of debate.
I don't have a very firm opinion on
this,
but when I think of a libertarian,
I think of somebody who says the state
should do the following.
Three things have a court system have
police force,
um,
and maybe enforced contracts,
something like that,
no more,
maybe some kind of very small social
minimum Milton Friedman negative income
tax type thing.
Whereas I think classical liberals are
more friendly to a more active state,
but I would also say that I'm happy to
say that libertarians are part of the
classical liberal family.
Yeah.
It's funny because I had done boudreaux
and here a couple of weeks ago talking
about this and I fall on that path where
the more I go down the libertarian roots
I really liked.
I liked that line of thinking.
I still think there's some utility of
the state,
but I think the more that you have these
conversations,
for me,
I'm finding it harder and harder to
defend anything related to the state,
which is a.
I Guess I'm taking a philosophically
fair approach to this because I'm taking
in new information.
Yeah.
I,
I'm,
I'm the same way.
So I think that the best arguments for
something like classical liberalism or
libertarianism is just the pervasiveness
of government failure.
So you know,
you look at where actual government
money goes,
not just not in theory,
but in practice where it goes,
um,
what sorts of groups are advantaged and
disadvantaged by the state?
I think that the government just doesn't
work very well and so the same reasons
why we don't want the government
producing food,
for example,
are also reasons why we might not want
the government in the business of say,
running school.
Right?
So do you think it will be fair to say
that if it ran well,
if this thing was a slim trim operation
and it was financially sensible and we
had people of good moral character in
the government in the rest of it,
that you'd actually have no reason to
be.
Certainly a libertarian and me perhaps
even a classical liberal,
you might actually be more,
have some sort of big government
democrat or something like that.
I think that's right.
So at least from my perspective,
so as I said,
I'm a fan of mill and utilitarianism.
The idea that the right thing is the
thing that produces the best results.
And so I think in a world in which the
state was run by angels,
very wise people,
very benevolent people,
and it produced good results.
I would be happy to accept a,
a big activist government or regulatory
and redistributive state,
but I think that are very powerful
reasons for thinking that that's not the
world that we live in.
So I think that some of my audience,
when they hear you talk about mill and
what's best for everyone,
they're going to view that through some
sort of lens of collectivism,
which is going to set some bells off.
So can you unpack that a little bit,
right?
Yeah.
So,
so for,
for what it's worth,
my view is that a system that produces
the most happiness,
the most flourishing,
the most prosperity is something like a
libertarian,
minimal state,
perhaps with a small social minimum.
So when you look historically at
collectivist regimes,
say the Soviet Union or North Korea or
something like that,
these don't have a good track record of
making people happy.
When you look at the societies that
actually make people happy compared to
the alternative,
they tend to be liberty limited.
Government free market,
a civil libertarian ish kind of states.
Alright.
So what other philosophers that's
affected you?
You're one for one.
Yeah,
John Stuart Mill.
Right up the top.
I'll give you somebody who you might not
like,
although he might not be familiar with
them.
Peter Singer who's a contemporary
utilitarian and a lot of people.
I think a lot of classical liberals and
libertarians aren't big fans of his,
although I think they need not,
not be fans of his.
So he's a,
he's famous for a number of things.
He has a number of very controversial
positions on a lot of things,
but one of his more famous thought
experiments involves you will imagining
that you're a walking somewhere and you
pass a small child who is drowning in a
shallow pond and you can save this child
at a very low cost to you.
Uh,
all,
all that's required is that you step
into the pond to get your shoes muddy
and pulled the child out.
But this means you'll have to spend 100
bucks on new shoes.
And he says,
clearly the sacrifice of $100 worth of
shoes is worth saving this child.
And so this suggests that we have strong
obligations to make personal sacrifices
for the betterment of the world's poor.
And I think that's right,
uh,
as at the level of moral principle,
for example.
But I think a lot of libertarians and
classical liberals worry that what this
is going to mean is we ought to have
large welfare states.
We ought to have billions of dollars
channeled into foreign aid and so on.
And I can understand why they make that
leap.
But I don't think that follows,
especially again,
if you look at the track record of
whether or not the government does a
good job of helping the poor and I think
it generally doesn't.
Yeah.
So,
and I definitely want to get to your
thoughts on that.
So do you view that sort of is like that
sort of like a micro macro argument that
at a micro level,
yeah,
you'd probably do it.
Like I'm sure if either one of us were
walking down the street,
we wouldn't care that much about our
shoes.
Enabled to save somebody,
but at a societal level,
we'd probably get swept out of your
economic arguments as well.
The more that you keep giving over to
society,
the more that it keeps taking in
essence,
individuals in their private lives,
uh,
if they do a good job of saying,
researching which private charities do a
good job of alleviating poverty in the
developing world.
And I think there are some,
then we would have in some sense in some
sense of societal obligation to help
just in the sense that most people of
means have this obligation to say donate
some of their paycheck to the against
malaria foundation for example.
But I think that doesn't justify saying
we want the state in the business of
redistributing income,
uh,
on a global level if only because it
just doesn't do a very good job of it
and oftentimes makes poverty even worse.
All right,
so you are a blogger at bleeding heart
libertarian.
Now,
I've seen this site before and check it
out again before,
uh,
before you got here.
But I thought the phrase bleeding heart,
libertarians,
that sort of sounds like what a
classical liberal is like,
right?
We got a little,
a little more heart in essence,
where we were okay with a little more
state to hopefully make sure that people
who need it the most are okay,
but I think a lot of people will see
those terms at odds.
Bleeding,
heart,
libertarian.
Yeah.
No,
and that's a great,
a great point too.
In light of the conversation about Peter
Singer,
because I do think that we have,
and I think a lot of classical liberals
agree that we have this strong
obligation to uphold political
institutions that work particularly well
for the poor.
And this isn't,
even though the term a bleeding heart,
libertarians is new.
This isn't just something that popped up
in the last five or six years.
If you go all the way back to Adam
Smith,
he has this,
this argument about the division of
Labor and free trade.
He says,
you know,
you sitting at your desk trying to make
pins all by yourself.
Maybe you could do two or three in a
day.
You have a division of labor where one
person straightening up the wire,
the other person's putting the pin on
the on the wire and so forth,
makes us massively more productive than
we otherwise could be,
and then through free trade are
everybody's welfare is increased,
but he stresses that this is
particularly good for the poor because
he says a society in which we're very
productive and we have this abundance of
material goods is a society in which
these sorts of goods are going to be a
lot cheaper and this is in fact what we
see,
uh,
and so a society in which the real price
of not just necessities but also things
that we might consider luxuries like
smartphones or something,
a society that makes those abundant and
cheap is a society that's very good for
the poor.
So I think a bleeding heart libertarian
or classical perspective is hundreds of
years old,
although you'd probably w we haven't
done a good job of marketing ourselves
perhaps.
Yeah.
How would you actually define what good
is that too tough for them?
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a big question.
So the,
here's the evasive answer is it depends
on which philosopher you're talking.
Yeah.
So,
so some philosophers think that so mill
has this view that the code consists of
pleasure,
but it's a sophisticated view where some
pleasures are of higher quality than
others.
So if I don't know you have pleasure as
a result of shooting up heroin and
that's equal in intensity and duration
to the pleasure that you get from
reading Shakespeare.
There's something qualitatively better
about the Shakespeare's and then the
heroin.
And so that's his view is that it's a
life of pleasure,
but where you have these high,
higher and lower pleasures,
other people,
other utilitarians think,
oh,
pleasure is created equal.
Other people have a maybe more
complicated views were a bunch of stuff,
makes a life good.
So it's pleasure.
It's knowledge,
it's living the morally virtuous life
and so on.
And this is a debate that we've been
having for $200 or 2000,
500 years with no end in sight.
I sense,
I know where you stand on that,
but you want to elaborate on that a
little bit more.
Well,
so I think that the,
yeah,
so it's a good question because you're
here as long as I'm here.
So what,
what is good?
Well,
so I think the good for a particular
person is probably,
um,
what a philosopher would call the
satisfaction of your informed
preferences.
So essentially getting what you want,
if you know what it is that you're
getting.
So for example,
you might want the liquid that is in
their glass right now because you have
the belief that it's water,
but if you have the fall,
if that belief is false because it turns
out to be vodka or something like that,
you might have a desire for what's in
there,
but the desire is in some sense informed
by this false belief.
But if you had perfectly true beliefs
about the world and then you desired say
that cup of water,
I said,
well that's good for you to get that
water.
You're getting what you want.
Yeah.
So you basically believe that
selfishness is good.
No,
because I think that a lot of people,
I think most people in fact have
preferences,
rational preferences for the welfare of
other people.
So I would say,
you know,
most,
can you make a selfish argument for that
because the way I've always sort of
understand,
or at least the way I use these words
now is by doing what is good for me.
That doesn't mean I want to ransack the
entire world.
I want to do good so that it's good for
my community.
I want to take care of my own house so
that my neighbor,
hopefully it will be like I'm next door
to someone with a nice house and we're
going to take care of their eyes.
So I've used selfishly,
I guess that's a little more of ran
thing where I've used selfishness
actually as a virtue.
Yeah.
So I think the difference would be in
say a case where you're,
you're a walking and see the child
drowning on the shallow pond,
the question would be,
well,
what is the reason why you're saving
this child and ruining their boots?
I think a good answer to that as well
because they care about the child's
welfare.
Um,
and then sometimes it's true that that's
a preference that you have.
So it's your preference.
And so you could call it a sort of self
guided or self preference,
but I wouldn't call it a selfish
preference in the sense that you expect
in some sense a this child's welfare to
directly translate into benefits for
you.
Right?
But you would feel good after,
I guess like you wouldn't if you'd be a
pretty twisted person if you were like,
well,
walking by like,
well what,
how's that gonna make me feel after a
little,
you should,
you should do what's right.
But I know what's right can often lead
to all sorts of bad things.
But I think you could make a selfish
argument for that.
Like you know that if you walk by a
child that you could easily help and you
don't,
you're going to feel shitty after if you
have any shred of conscious.
Right.
So I hope right on sociopaths,
I hope have that,
have that sort of psychological
disposition and as far as sort of once.
So I think also what morality is more
concerned with is not just the good of
the individual,
but sort of the good of all.
So I think for what the morally right
thing to do is figuring out the
decision.
So this is the kind of million
utilitarian view that the right thing to
do is basically that which produces the
most good for everybody,
not just an individual person.
So it could be in some cases that,
uh,
a person's individual good comes apart
from what's morally good.
So you could imagine somebody who just
has no desire to help other people.
I would still say they're doing
something morally wrong if they fail to
help other people because they're not
taking that person's welfare into
account.
Right.
So where do you think morals come from?
This has been an ongoing discussion on
this show between,
you know,
talking to Jordan Peterson and bench and
Sam Harris and Michael Shermer,
Dennis Prager,
and many others.
And there's sort of a religious
argument.
I think there's a secular argument for
it.
Um,
I think I'm somewhere in the middle.
I think it's a really rich spot to
figure out what people think about
things.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's a,
that's a hard question.
Uh,
I'm not sure I have a satisfying answer
to that.
So,
but maybe in terms of the religious
question there,
this very old argument from Plato,
the EUTHYPHRO dilemma.
I'm not sure if that's ever popped up in
conversation,
but the idea is basically,
uh,
does,
does God will something because it's
pious independently of God's will or is
it pious because God wills it and
Plato's view was,
well,
uh,
it doesn't quite make sense to say that
it's pious just because God wills it
because you could imagine as a thought
experiment that God willing all sorts of
terrible family just as,
as a thought experiment that,
you know,
if God wills us to torture it doesn't
seem like that would make torture good.
Um,
and so it seems more plausible to think
that there is sort of an independent
standard of goodness even,
even if you are a theist,
for example,
in,
you believe in God and you believe God
has this intimate connection to
morality.
I think even on views like that,
it make sense to say that goodness is in
some sense independent of the will of
God.
And so in terms of what more,
that's again,
sort of an evasive answer as to what.
It's not a where morality comes from.
I mean,
I'm inclined to say it.
I mean it comes from sort of what's good
for human beings and maybe other and
animals.
So what sorts of things satisfy or
interest to our preferences causes
pleasure and pain,
these sorts of things.
Do you think that subjective though,
that the different cultures obviously
have different beliefs and different
moralities and all sorts of things?
I would say it is not subjective in the
sense that a different different
cultures having different moral beliefs
would show that nobody's wrong in those
debates.
So it might be very difficult to
determine who is wrong,
but I don't think the mere fact that
different cultures have moral standards
shows that it's subjective.
So by analogy,
uh,
you could imagine different cultures
having different beliefs about astrology
for example.
So some cultures think that astrology is
legitimate enterprise.
Other ones don't.
They disagree about that.
But I think it's safe to say that there
is in some sense and objectively correct
answer about that.
Uh,
same thing with other sorts of
scientific disputes,
right?
But do you think that that objective
place,
does that have to come from God per se?
Or can it come from,
I mean,
the,
the discussion that we've had a lot
around here that a lot of people in this
space talk about basically is,
does objective morality either come from
God and religion or does it come from
enlightened enlightenment and values?
And then there's other arguments that
it's only through religion that we got
to enlightenment values in the.
Yeah,
that's tough.
My hunch is that something like
enlightenment values,
um,
so I don't know.
I'm somewhere in the agnostic space,
uh,
myself.
Uh,
and so I think that sort of philosophy
guy,
right?
Exactly.
So it's hard not to.
It's hard not to be an agnostic.
So,
uh,
yeah,
so I'm agnostic,
but I'm also Jewish and so there's,
it's all part of the kind of
questioning,
lack of certainty and so forth.
So I think that there is,
there's enough reason to think that we
have objective morality,
even if you're not certain about the
existence of God.
Um,
that yeah,
we shouldn't worry that morality is
going to collapse if people become
atheist and agnostic.
Right?
Because when I've had this discussion
usually with conservatives,
you know,
they love to say,
well,
God gave us morality.
You know what I mean?
Your rights come from God.
And for me it's like I think you have
whether they're God,
God given rights or it's your right,
freedom is your right as a human being
or as optimist prime said,
freedom is the right of all sentient
beings.
You don't.
You're like,
I think you are born free.
I just think that's a,
that's a humanistic approach or your
boyfriend.
The government can take away your
freedom but he doesn't give it to you.
And I think that's just a really
interesting place to go for all these
political discussions.
So I,
that's why I think that there are right
and wrong ways to treat other human
beings that are just true independently
of whether or not the state happens to
respect them and as soon as the kind of
enlightenment thought.
So John Locke's I'd look in the state of
nature,
I would be wrong to kill you or assault
you or steal your property.
This is just the wrong way to treat
human beings.
It doesn't really have anything to do
with the state.
Now he might want the state to come in
and protect those rights,
enforce those rights and so on.
But the rates themselves,
the standard of the right and wrong way
to treat other people does not itself
come from the state or.
So before we get into some of your
specific arguments that you make on
economics and a bunch budget,
how do you think are our founders got so
much of this stuff right?
If I'm going on the assumption you
believe they did,
but I mean every time I go to DC and I
go to the monuments and I read all of
this stuff and I just was in philly
yesterday,
I mentioned to you and I have now a copy
of that little copy Republican senator
of the declaration and the Declaration
of independence.
The alarm at the,
there was this thing,
it would set off the TSA alarms at the.
Oh,
this one's just standard simple paper,
whatever.
It's probably will set off some alarm
somewhere.
I'm sure if I go to San Francisco or
something,
I'm sure a constitution would set off an
alarm.
But,
um,
uh,
I assume you think that they got a much
of this stuff correctly.
How do you think they did it?
Yeah,
so I think that,
I don't know.
So I think that some of it,
and this is a bit outside of my area,
but I think that a lot of them were
influenced by the smart philosophers.
People like.
So I think the law,
the influence of someone like lock on a
constitution,
it's pretty evident the influence of
somebody like David Hume on people like
Madison.
I think that's,
I think that maybe that's a matter of
controversy in history,
but I think there's some evidence to
suggest that.
So I think that they were students of
history,
students of philosophy,
students of economics,
and this helped them get a lot right.
And I think,
you know,
obviously I think there were mistakes
and the way that they applied it and um,
you know,
the way that,
uh,
like Jefferson's a omission of mentions
of slavery and things like that.
But I think in terms of like the
fundamentals,
a lot of that was informed by really
smart philosophers and economists.
Well,
they were,
they were all philosophers in their own
right and they were inconsistent as,
as people in their own time,
which is why I'm so fascinated with that
period of history.
All right,
so let's talk about some of the
specifics here.
So I wanted to go to one that I think we
disagree on,
but I want you to,
I want you to make the most compelling
case that you can,
uh,
this open border stuff.
Yes.
So you're not,
you're not a,
I'm not an open borders guy.
This is a,
I'm not a crazy borders person or
whatever that means.
I don't,
I don't think.
I don't think there should be no
immigration.
We are a nation of immigrants.
That's what's made this melting pot,
I think the greatest nation in the
history of the world that's given more
freedom to more people than,
than anyone ever.
Um,
but the open border situation,
especially now in 2018,
2018 strikes me as particularly tenuous,
but take it away.
So I,
I think one thing to keep in mind is
what exactly a,
an advocate of open borders is arguing
for.
So I think most so open borders is maybe
a bit of a misnomer.
It's more light borders are porous
borders or something like that.
Where.
So the idea wouldn't be that there's
perhaps no checkpoints are no
restrictions on immigration.
Just very few.
So I think most open border folks would
be happy saying that if you are a
wanted,
violent criminal that might exclude you
from immigrating if you have some
particularly deadly contagious disease
and so forth.
But other than that,
a sort of ordinary,
peaceful migrants should be able to come
to the United States.
As far as the,
the argument goes,
I think they're really two strands.
One is just that the,
the economic benefits of immigration are
huge.
So the most optimistic estimates say
that we could potentially double world
of GDP by opening borders.
So we've done a pretty good job of
opening up trade.
We've done a much worse job opening up
borders,
but in terms of the productivity gains
that it would be incredible better than
anything else.
We could do a.
and this goes back to what I was
discussing earlier with our obligations
to the global poor.
Foreign aid doesn't have a good track
record.
Military intervention doesn't have a
good track record,
but allowing people to move from places
with lower wages to higher wages is by
far the best antipoverty tool that we
have.
So if we were going to get into the
nitty gritty number that,
what do you actually have to do then to
secure the borders,
right?
Because that's really what this is
about.
So even if you make every economic
argument that I'm like,
all right,
I can't riddled my way out of that,
right?
Like if I'm on board that you still have
to do something to make sure that you're
doing those things,
making sure that murderers are coming in
and all of that.
And we don't seem very good at that.
And I think maybe that's the leap that
gets me to where I can't make the
secondary part that you're talking about
here.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure about the policy.
I mean,
something like the old Ellis island
system seems pretty good.
I mean,
we had a ton of immigration,
um,
back then,
but there still was some kind of a
checking mechanism.
So as far so I doubt that that involves
building a wall,
um,
but having some kind of centralized
location where immigrants can come and
get documents and things like that
seems,
seems pretty reasonable.
Uh,
but that's probably the most detail I
could give you on policy ideas.
So then when you go over these borders
then your gut,
you would want these people to be
governed by the laws of the place that
they were in,
right?
That's right,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
so I would be happy to write a,
an allow ordinary,
peaceful migrants to come in and then
apply for US citizenship.
Just,
you know,
uh,
make it pretty easy to do that.
Is this though a tough one for a guy
that doesn't trust the government that
much?
Because that's what's ringing with me
here.
And when I've heard this argument,
it's like,
alright wait,
if you don't trust the government,
well then why do you think the
government would be able to vet people
properly?
Especially because we now see what's
going on in Europe where they've vetted
people very poorly and have had very
poorest borders.
So this might.
Yeah.
So I don't know.
I think though,
if you're a skeptic of the government,
so presumably you're a free trade
advocate,
you like jed across borders.
You wouldn't be happy with governments
micromanaging trade across borders
because you're a skeptic about how well
the government works as am I,
and for the same sorts of reasons.
I'm skeptical.
So I think if you're worried about the
government working well,
that's all the more reason to get it out
of the immigration regulation business.
So it might,
I think you're probably right.
It does a bad job of a lot of stuff.
Almost everything.
Um,
so the standard here is not going to be
perfection,
but just what's the best alternative,
heavily regulated immigration or lightly
immigrated regulation.
And I think all things equal lightly,
lightly regulated immigration will
probably be better.
Let me give you another argument too.
So this again is maybe a more
libertarian classical liberal argument
for immigration,
but it just seems like people have a
right to,
to move across borders.
So for example,
if,
uh,
you know,
I dunno a this table for example,
we're divided by some kind of border and
I said,
well look,
I want you to come over to my side and
rent my house from me or work in my
business or join my religious
congregation.
And you said,
okay,
I do want to do those things.
And we both agree on this.
We,
we agree on the terms.
And then the state sort of intervenes as
a third party in this,
what this philosopher Robert nozick
would call a capitalist act between
consenting adults.
It seems like they wouldn't be violating
our rights to associate with one another
on free terms.
And so I think there's a reason to think
that a border controls violate people's
natural rights.
Is there also some inherent problem
though that let's say most of the
Western society is the freest society's
got onboard.
This will then they would end up being
flooded with people where maybe the
economics don't work out.
Because if we just say,
I mean if you think about it,
like if tomorrow we were just like,
all right,
everybody can come.
And just as long as you're not a
murderer or be a drug dealer,
you're good to go.
That there must be so mechanistic theory
here where we're going to lead in a
certain amount of people at your
economics are gonna work out and then
we're going to get to some odd tipping
point where because freedom is pretty
good,
people are gonna want in on it.
Yeah.
So I think there are a couple of things
to say.
So one is just if we.
I think that problem to some extent
would be self correcting.
So if you think that a lot of the
pressure to migrate is economics.
So people are moving from low wage
countries to higher wage countries.
Those you have more and more people
enter the high wage,
high wage countries.
This would increase the total number of
workers which would probably start
dropping down their wages.
And so you would probably see less
motivation to move.
I think that's one thing,
but as a,
as a concession to this word,
what I would say is we can do it slowly.
So for example,
if we're really worried about these
affects of dramatically increasing
immigration overnight,
what we could do is just say increase,
say the limits on immigration by 10
percent every year or something like
that,
and take it slowly and see where it
goes.
But it wouldn't have to push the button.
Open the borders overnight if we have
this worry.
What do you think is philosophically
the,
the soundest way to deal with the people
that are already here?
Uh,
I,
yeah,
so I am an advocate of the view that you
don't have an obligation to obey unjust
laws.
And so I think that our immigration laws
are unjust.
So I think people who came here,
uh,
even against current immigration law,
I think they should just amnesty full
citizenship.
That's,
that would be my approach to that,
Huh?
Yeah.
All right.
We're not quite there,
but it's all good.
Let me ask you this.
So you're not a fan of the drug war?
No,
I'm not.
Okay.
So suppose we have somebody who is in
jail for selling marijuana.
It's like this,
um,
and then suppose that.
Yeah.
So they're breaking was a citizen of the
United States citizens,
but who broke say current immigration,
not immigration,
current drug laws.
Do you think that they violated some
moral obligation that they had a not to
break us drug or do you say,
well what good is it bad law?
So they didn't do anything?
Well,
partly I think it would depend on the
specific offense.
So we're.
So whether they were using drugs or
selling drugs,
I would see a distinction there.
So if there's someone that.
And there are people that are in jail
for using drugs right now for using pot,
I think those,
those laws are unjust and I would want
to do everything I could to reverse
those laws and reversed the,
the prison system,
the justice system and all that.
As far as the dealers,
yeah,
you can't until until we fix these laws
and figuring out what actually is fair
and change some classifications on
marijuana and a bunch of other things.
It's tough.
I think it's tough.
I don't think you can free drug dealers
per se.
Even though you're a guy,
you don't think they did something that
should be against the law,
the people that are doing the drugs,
I think you have a right to do with your
body as you see fit.
But again,
but again,
if you break a law you have to like,
I would change the laws is what I'm
saying,
but if you break a law then you have to
suffer the consequences of that.
So does that all work out?
I'm curious,
I don't know.
Forgive me for this,
but.
So suppose you have a drug user who's
convicted of this offense and they're,
they're in jail,
but suppose they can escape from prison
harmlessly.
Um,
do you think they would be doing
something morally wrong by escaping from
prison?
All right,
so this is a good little,
right?
We're doing students,
so students.
No,
this is great.
I mean this is what it's about,
right?
So,
okay.
So let's say someone was smoking weed at
home.
Cops bust in there,
thrown in jail for three years.
It's a year or two and they're going to
pull the shawshank and get out of there.
Do I think they're morally.
The question is,
do I think they're morally right for
doing it or can that be morally
justified?
So.
Right.
So what are we morally criticize them if
they pull the shawshank where they
escaped to the wall or something like
that,
and they don't harm anyone.
They just,
they just leave because they say I was
convicted of something that ought not be
a crime,
so I don't owe any morally moral
allegiance to that law and so I'm just
going to escape.
Would you hear about this story?
Do you say?
I'd be rooting for that guy.
I wouldn't be rooting for that.
So that's kind of my perspective on
immigration that I think that it's an
unjust law and justice people are under
an obligation to obey the state with
respect to the drug war.
Yeah.
I don't think people are under an
obligation to be the state with respect
to immigration.
Right.
So I guess our sort of disconnecting on
this is just the unjustness of
immigration laws versus drug laws.
Right?
Right.
So if you think that the law itself is
not unjust than my argument won't have
any kind of grip on you.
Yeah.
I'm not saying our immigration laws are
just by the way,
I just think that especially now,
uh,
also just because of terrorism and
people move and just when you see what's
going on with Europe and,
and because it hasn't just been a people
trying to get over for humanitarian
purposes there we know that there's a
lot of migrants and all sorts of other
people and then assimilation problems
and then welfare state problems.
Like it just seems like it's become this
massive thing that most of Europe would
probably do it very differently if they
could look back eight years ago.
Right?
Yeah.
So as far as the terrorism point goes,
I mean,
I think if somebody is a one to
terrorist or a suspected terrorist,
that's a perfectly legitimate reason not
to,
not to allow them in a.
and I'm less concerned about the,
the assimilation concern,
the welfare state concern.
So as far as the,
the assimilation where he goes,
I mean,
a lot of the evidence I've seen suggests
that the political values of immigrants
and especially second generation
American immigrants is almost identical
to the political,
a political values held by a native born
Americans.
Um,
and as far as the welfare state concern
goes,
um,
I would say we have lots of other
freedoms that can potentially increase
the cost of the welfare state.
And we're okay with people exercising
them.
So for example,
uh,
you know,
I dunno,
we allow people to choose their own
profession,
for example,
in the United States.
And so suppose you have a student who
says,
here's what I want to do with my life.
I want to become a philosopher.
He said,
well,
that's a dicey career choice,
not a lot of money in it.
Who knows,
maybe you'll end up on unemployment and
this will in fact increase the cost of
the welfare state because now you have
this person on unemployment because they
chose to become a philosopher with our
life.
We say,
well,
uh,
we,
we let them do that.
We let them to exercise that freedom,
to choose that occupation,
even knowing that this might increase
the costs of the welfare state.
And so I think you can make an analogous
argument about immigration if you think
it's a right and important human
freedom,
then you say,
well,
this is sort of a price of respecting
rights and respecting freedom.
They sometimes can impose costs on third
parties.
So if all these people come here,
then what,
what duty does the state have to make
sure that they don't just get here and
can't do anything and then then more
crime comes and drugs and the rest of
it.
Yeah.
Their responsibility for the state at
that point.
I'm not sure that the responsibility of
the state to immigrants is different
from their responsibility to citizens.
So I think part.
So,
uh,
I mean there's also a question of what
we would do in the ideal world versus
the real world to say in the ideal world
of somebody like Milton Friedman,
the welfare state is much smaller and
maybe you have something like the
negative income tax.
This isn't the world we live in.
We have over a trillion dollars of
redistributive spending every year.
I mean I don't.
So,
so there are two separate issues.
So one is this imperial claim about
whether immigrants tend to consume more
in government services than they pay in
taxes and it seems like the fiscal
effect is pretty moderate.
So some estimates say they do in fact
raise fiscal costs a little bit.
Others?
No.
In fact actually there's a net benefit
because a lot of a lot of new immigrants
aren't consuming a lot of government
services and so forth and they're paying
sales tax and things like this,
but I think that again,
this is a concession.
If you really have to worry about the
welfare state,
we could say,
well maybe this is not my view,
but if,
if,
if this is what it took for me to get
you over to my side,
I'll give you this.
I'll give you this concession.
We could say something like,
you have a five year waiting period
before you have access to unemployment
benefits and whatnot.
I would take that over border closure if
those were the only two options.
It's tough being intellectually honest,
isn't it?
Because you have to,
you have to conceive things every now
and again,
which you just don't see people doing
anymore.
So it seems like doubling.
That's just,
this is just a ploy to get you and your
viewers to Lord on my side.
So yeah,
I don't care so much about the honesty.
Just get people on the open borders
side.
All right,
so you've argued that inequality of
income is in the real issue,
but poverty is the real issue,
right?
Let's get into the weeds on that.
Okay,
good.
So sometimes you'll hear,
this is sometimes philosophers,
but oftentimes politicians,
they'll make statements like two percent
of a American earners have 40 percent of
the country's wealth or something like
that.
And from here we're supposed to infer
that some injustice has occurred because
there's this,
this large inequality.
And I think,
uh,
I mean there might be an injustice
there,
uh,
but we can't tell a strictly on the
basis of the inequality.
So there's a philosopher named Robert
Nozick who famously said,
what matters isn't so much the income
distribution that we end up with,
but how we got there.
So if somebody has a huge amount of
wealth but they got it through theft or
the God had through lobbying the
government for special privileges,
this is very bad.
This is something that we shouldn't
encourage.
On the other hand,
if we have somebody who has a lot of
wealth because they invented the iphone
and there are tens,
if not hundreds of millions of people
who want to buy this,
that's totally fine.
So we can't just look at the pie and how
it's carved up and say whether it's just
or unjust.
We have to see that people make their
money by making other people better off
by giving them things that they wanted.
Or did they take it through fraudulent
means?
Coercive means.
And I think that the talk about
inequality oftentimes confuses a quality
with poverty.
So is what we're really concerned with
equalizing income or are we concerned
about making the poor better off?
And I think it's the latter that we
really should care about.
So how do we go ahead and do that?
Well,
so opening borders I think is the first
step in terms of alleviating global
inequality,
or.
I'm sorry,
global poverty I think is the best thing
that we can do.
I think domestically there are a lot of
government policies that really do harm
to,
to the most disadvantaged groups.
So I think opening up school choice
would be a great idea.
I think.
I think the drug war would be a great
idea.
I think ending occupational licensing
would be a very good idea.
So enabling people to work in certain
industries or start their own business
with a lot less red tape is a very good
idea.
And wouldn't barbers be stabbing people
that says,
well this is what I say.
There are some states where you have to,
you have to get licensed to shampoo
people.
But I shampoo my.
I'm,
I'm pulling my hair every morning and
doing this and I probably shouldn't say
that.
Yeah,
do I do with myself?
I combed my hair without a license.
And so far the government hasn't come
after me and I haven't poked my eye on.
Yeah.
So what's your,
what's your best argument then when the
people that don't buy into this and say,
well we need these regulations because
you're going to have people that don't
know how to dye hair are going to be
scalding people's heads and you know,
Mr Burns is going to be dumping nuclear
waste into the Springfield river and all
of those things.
What's the best argument against them?
So one argument is just that I don't
think regulation works very well and I
don't think so.
I think the way that the public views
regulation is probably misguided.
So I don't think the regulators are bad
people,
but I think if you examine the ways that
regulations are formed and operate in
the real world,
it's oftentimes to protect the,
the interest of the industries that
they're regulating.
So this is what's known as regulatory
capture,
where regulators aren't always looking
out for the public interest or actually
looking out for the interests of people
in that industry.
So financial regulation is a case of
this.
You have lobbyists who might be friends
with people in the financial sector,
they want to work in the financial
sector later or vice versa.
And so they're often very friendly to
the very people that they're regulating.
Um,
and as far as you know,
the,
the worry about scolding people and so
forth.
Um,
I think that competition itself is a
kind of regulation.
So in the case of,
of school choice,
it's true.
You might have very bad charter schools
for example,
but again,
the standard here is not perfection.
The standard is what's the alternative.
So we have public schools that are
terrible,
but charter schools have this advantage
of enabling people to choose.
So if you go to a charter school that's
failing,
you can pull your kids out and put them
somewhere else.
And that's a kind of regulation in the
sense that it provides incentives to the
providers to supply good service.
So it's almost like we should rely on
self regulation or not regulation,
not even self regulation in a sense.
So this is something that comes up when
I,
when I argue with people,
is they think that I have this view of
private business,
uh,
as,
as being sort of benevolent where
they'll just take care of themselves.
I have a sense of the public interest.
I think maybe to some extent that's
true,
but it's more the kind of Smithian
insight where if you have providers who
are competing for my business,
they don't have to care about my welfare
directly or the welfare of my family,
but they might just want my money and
that itself is an incentive for them to
provide good,
safe service.
So in a sense it's competition for
dollars,
competition for customers that acts as
the regulations.
So I think the market as a whole is self
regulating,
self correcting.
So you're also a universal basic income
supporter.
Yeah.
Now this is a idea that comes from
economists on the left.
I've heard some interesting sort of
libertarian arguments from it from
people,
but what is your take on?
So this goes back to the idea that it is
important to take care of people who are
in poverty or who might've fallen on
hard luck and it needs some help getting
back on their feet.
I might.
My short pitch for the universal basic
income would just be,
suppose you could take,
I forget what the number is,
but you know,
over a trillion dollars of
redistributive spending that the United
States government does a social
security,
medicare,
medicaid,
unemployment,
all of these things.
Suppose we said,
okay,
you can remove all that and just get
some kind of cash payout if you fall
below a certain level of poverty.
So this is kind of the Milton Friedman
idea,
a where you get sort of more and more
money the further below the poverty line
you are.
So you can see the whole apparatus of
the welfare state with its bureaucracy
and inefficiency and just replace that
with a universal basic income.
I make that trade every day of the week.
Do you think that that would
disincentivize people to actually the
people that are right above that marker?
I mean,
do you know where you put that Marcus?
So I don't know,
I don't have the specifics of where I
would put it,
but the idea is that we,
uh,
so the way that a friedman structured
the idea of the negative income tax is
that you would still get more total
income by working and making more money
so you would see some decrease in the
cash grants that you get from the
government,
but it wouldn't be so massive as to
disincentivize so they would be trend
but they wouldn't be trimmed so much
that you have no incentive to,
to go to where do you see that as?
Just like some sort of inconsistency
with the way that you generally view
government because you're obviously not
a big government guy.
And yet this is something that's really
like I would view this as something that
this is like government should have no
place in giving that much to people.
Like it's kind of shitty.
Like I'd love to figure out better ways
to help people who need it the most.
Um,
but the idea of giving more,
I just don't know that there's evidence
that it works.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so I think though that if that objection
is successful will also be successful
about a,
against something like private charity
for example.
So I think there always is this worry
that when you give some kind of
assistance that this will have negative
effects on people's incentives to work.
I think that's,
I think that's probably true to some
extent,
but that might just be a cost that we
have to live with.
So I think again,
even if you're doing some sort of
private charity that might lessen at the
margin people's willingness to go to
work,
but I think that trade off is worth it
if it means say that,
uh,
we have people who aren't starving who
aren't very sick without help,
but I do.
So again,
a concession that I will make because I
think by and large,
private charity will work much better
than sort of state bureaucratic charity,
um,
or,
or transfer programs,
some philosophical level.
Doesn't that also make people feel
better?
Like the idea that like right now
government just does
things and it either does them
inefficiently or not,
you don't really know where your money's
going and you kind of just are like,
you can just easily be like,
yeah,
I'm for poor people because the
government's doing it where when you
actually go ahead and do things and go
ahead and volunteer and go ahead and
give charity and all that,
that just philosophically for your own
goodness and happiness and things that
we've talked about that that's probably
much more rewarding.
I think so.
Right.
It's very,
it's very easy and low cost to just cast
a vote for some policy or politician
that happens to align with your values.
That doesn't really,
you know,
the price of that is very low,
but right.
Actually say doing some research,
figuring out what causes you support a,
putting money into those things.
Right.
I think that's much more gratifying.
I think we should get more and moral
credit for doing that than just voting
for policies that you'd like to.
Is that sort of thing?
Basic disconnect between Democrats and
Republicans in this point.
Like I view it as sort of Democrats are
kind of like,
we'll just do everything for you.
We're going to say all the nice things
and do it for you.
And Republicans are just like,
we're not.
We.
Well,
they ended up doing it anyway because
they had.
Once they're empowered,
they're always spending the money
anyway,
but they seem like the evil guys because
they don't want to do it.
Then they do it anyway,
but that's what it really comes down to.
It's like one set of people who were
saying we're gonna do all the nice
things and then doing them even when the
results are a nice and another set who
doesn't,
don't say they want to do the nice
things,
but then they end up doing it and the
result results
still aren't great.
Well,
so.
So I'm not sure.
Although I do remember this book I
probably a little old by now called who
really cares by Arthur Brooks.
Have you ever come across?
So he's.
I think now he's the president,
have a right.
And what he did find that there were
differences in charitable giving between
Democrats and Republicans are,
I'm not sure if it was along party lines
or ideological lines more broadly,
and he did find evidence that
conservatives tend to give more
privately than Democrats.
Uh,
there might be a variety of explanations
for that.
So one explanation might just be that
conservatives tend to be more skeptical
of the efficacy of these large scale
bureaucracies.
Like how well do they actually work?
I think there's maybe also this,
this idea that it's the role of
something like the family or the church
or civil society to take care of people
who are in poverty rather than the
states.
And so maybe that's why you see
conservatives given more charitable
dollars than people on the left.
Alright.
So I want to finish up with a couple,
a scientific experiment that you've
written about.
Oh Wow.
I got a couple here.
Let's see how sharp you are on the
previous work you've done.
All right.
Talk to me about the Stanford prison
experiment credit.
Yeah.
So.
Oh man,
that's.
Yeah,
that's gone back.
Right?
So this was a,
this was research around here,
I don't just sit down with people and
you know,
I think you know,
my work better than that.
So that was an experiment that was
conducted,
I,
I want to say in the early seventies by
a Stanford psychologist,
and he recruited a more or less ordinary
young men to serve in this experiment.
And uh,
some of the subjects were cast as
prisoners in this fake prison and other
subjects were cast as the prison guards
in this experiment.
And so they were enforcing the prison
rules and feeding the prisoners and uh,
having them go to sleep at specified
times and so forth.
And to make a long story short,
what he found was that the power given
to the students who were the prison
guards did have this corrupt and effect
to this idea that power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely seem
to be supported by his experiments.
So very quickly,
I think in a matter of days,
what you found were the guards who are,
again,
we're drawing from the same demographic
pool as the,
as the prisoners were abusing the
prisoners,
were mocking them,
uh,
and he had to cut it short because
essentially the wheels came off of this
experiment and the prisoners got so
abuse or the prison guards got so
abusive.
And so this I think,
confirms this idea that,
uh,
you don't have to be a bad person to
allow power to have this corrupting
effect on their behavior.
There must be plenty of other studies
proving that,
right?
Even through just the prison system.
I mean,
when I feel like every prison movie I've
ever watched,
orange is the new black.
I mean,
the people that are in charge of the
prisons usually are pretty bad people.
Yeah.
And like I said,
they could be perfectly ordinary.
And there's also the,
the milgram experiments where,
which are kind of the,
uh,
the classic case of this where you just
have people who are in essence willing
to torture,
give electric shocks to complete
strangers because somebody in authority
told them to do so.
And the subjects figure out ways to
rationalize why these electric shocks
are justified,
you know,
the person should have behaved
differently and they wouldn't have
gotten the shocks.
And what's really frightened about this
is it does show that ordinary people,
people like,
uh,
you know,
you and I could easily see our behavior
corrupted given the right sort of
institution.
What do you do as a human knowing that,
what do you do to,
to insulate yourself while.
So one thing I think is to be very
skeptical of these sorts of institutions
which give people lots of power over
others.
I think that's one of the big picture
lessons from these sorts of experiments.
Experiments is just be wary of,
of giving people power on an individual
level.
Knowing about it I think helps a little
bit,
but even more than just knowing about
it.
I think I'm practicing it so when you
know that you're in a position,
say to do something wrong because you
feel the social pressure to do it on a
small level,
I'm just try to resist that impulse and
actually do the right thing,
so I don't think it's the sort of thing
that you can condition yourself to do
overnight to resist malevolent authority
or resist becoming a malevolent
authority,
but you could take small steps,
but Kinda it's like practicing an
athletic skill or something like that.
You don't try dunking a basketball the
first time you pick it up,
but you take these small incremental
steps and you'll get better and better.
Hopefully built character traits and
then maybe resistant when the situation
becomes more dire.
It's interesting because that's sort of
reminds me of the way that we see virtue
signaling happening on social media
these days.
It's not that we're all deciding we have
this power and we can shock somebody,
but it's like you find someone
halfway across the world who says
something you slightly disagree with.
Even though you've never heard of them
before.
You start seeing the mob go at them and
the next thing you know,
you ratchet up more and then someone
else ratcheted up more and more and it's
all done in the name of being good
actually.
The way you're trying to shame and
destroyed his person.
Yeah,
they're in there,
right?
There's something kind of
psychologically gratifying about being
part of a moralizing mob.
And I think that's an impulse that does
have to be resisted.
Right?
So it's virtue signaling.
It's not actually,
it's not actually exactly.
Actual virtue would be saying something
like,
well,
I,
you know,
I think everybody here is wrong about
what the right thing to do is here.
That's usually a pretty lonely guy.
It's true.
That's true.
All right,
one more.
Sure.
The asch conformity experiment.
Yeah.
So that's along the same line as the
Stanford prison experiment and the
milgram experiments in this,
I think this was the,
one of the originals.
It was in the 19 fifties and subjects
were given,
uh,
a board which had lines of different
lengths on them.
So like there was one that was very long
when it was moderately long,
when it was short,
for example,
uh,
and then they were given another line
that they were told was the same length
is one of the lines on the other board
and it was very obvious.
So it was like this was a,
like a,
a very long line over here.
And there was a very long line over
here.
They were clearly the same length but
they were surrounded by other lines of
various line.
But it was just as very easy test until
they asked subjects.
Well,
which line over here is the same length
as this line over here?
And everybody knew what the correct
answer was,
but the twist of the experiment was a.
The experimenter would bring in
confederates who would lie and give the
obviously false answers.
So they would say,
oh,
in fact it turns out that the short line
over here is the same length as this
long line over here.
And what they wanted to test was whether
the genuine subject would conform to the
mistaken group judgment,
which they need to be clearly wrong,
or would they stick to their guns and
say,
no,
everybody in this room is wrong.
It's clearly,
you know,
this line here and everybody else made a
mistake.
And the depressing result is that many
people would not just conform once,
but would conform over and over again to
the judgment that they knew was wrong.
And even people who sometimes broke from
the group would have at least a couple
of answers where they conform to the
group answer.
So is that just
sort of basic built in DNA that just
certain people are going to stand up for
what they believe in?
What's right and what's true and most of
us aren't?
Or is that,
can you.
Can you really like Steven pinker?
Right?
Well I believe pinker would say
something about a blank slate.
Right?
So.
So I'm not sure.
Right.
He might.
He might say it's something close to our
DNA.
I'm not sure.
It's interesting when you read testimony
from people in the milgram experiments,
there were some people who just refused
to deliver these shocks to people even
though there was a lot of pressure on
them and it seems like some of them had
life experiences that really discouraged
them from a obeying the authority and it
wouldn't shock me,
no pun intended,
if there was something like that going
on in these conformity experiments where
maybe people have seen the malevolent
effects of blind conformity in this
motivated them to do it.
Uh,
so yeah,
so I'm not sure whether it's nature or
nurture.
I don't know.
That's probably above my pay grade.
All right.
As long as you mentioned pinker,
this I think will be a good way to wrap
this all up.
Are you hopeful as,
as a philosopher,
are you hopeful for free thought?
I mean,
a lot of people that care about the
conversations that we're having are
really worried and I find that the
people that are most closely associated
with that I have these conversations
with most,
I would say most of us are sort of world
weary optimists.
That's how I would describe myself,
like if I wasn't hopeful,
I don't know how the Hell I could do
this everyday,
right.
Like I'm hopeful that we can make things
better and yet at the same time there's
no doubt we have an uphill battle and
that there's so much history all the
time and all the forces that we're not
into seem to be on the march all the
time.
But are you hopeful?
I like that term world where he
optimists,
I think that probably describes me
pretty well and part of the reason I'm
optimistic is because oftentimes when I
think when you're interacting with
people on a one on one level,
you're more likely to have a civil
productive discussion about
controversial topics.
Then when it's like these huge,
like I just gave this talk I think
recently at a college and you got my
brother give me an hour of
philosophically not at University of New
Hampshire.
Oh,
okay.
Right.
Yeah.
And so I think in those,
so talking about like virtue signaling
and a mob mentality,
I think those sorts of settings are
conducive to that.
I think oftentimes when you're just
talking with a person over a beer,
you might have completely different
politics than they do,
but it's kind of a,
a nonthreatening sort of friendly
situation.
I think people's guards go down a little
bit more and those sorts of situations
and you can actually have a conversation
about controversial topics in good faith
and so that I.
So I think people want that.
I think people want to have these kinds
of discussions and arguments and it
might be the people who are a least
friendly to that sort of thing,
get the most visibility or get the most
publicity,
but I think if you took an average
person off the street and said,
hey,
let's grab a beer and talk about
politics,
it wouldn't be nearly as bad as you
know,
doing it in front of 50,000
people.
I agree.
And that's why I said the thing about
the 80 percent before,
and I think in summation,
you believe that beer is the great
philosophical equalizer.
Maybe Bourbon.
I'm not really at,
not beer.
You've got this great thing over here.
So yeah.
So Bourbon is Bourbon whiskey that.
On that note we should wrap this up and
see what we can do with the Bourbon.
Alright for more on Chris Checkout see
fryman.com,
which we'll link to write down below.